welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown and
revisitation of Marvel's Loki season 1
episode 1 glorious purpose so a lot has
changed in the MCU since I first broke
this series down and with season 2
coming up on Disney plus October 6th it
definitely felt like time for a rewatch
and you know what we were able to find
so many more details in Easter eggs I
don't know how but we were so let's go
back through the six episodes of Loki
season 1 starting with this one with a
fresh perspective to find out why Miss
minutes haunts my H oh come on come on
not fair we open on New York City 2012
during Loki's escape and Avengers
endgame The Avengers theme plays as the
letters in the New York title card cycle
through the options before settling like
old train station flip slap displays the
date actually starts on that swipe in
2025 if you look at those blurry numbers
and then swipes back in time until we
land on 2012 as if Kang is moving a dial
until he gets to the option that he
wants now that Quantum Mania has come
out along with trailers for Loki season
2 we know that he remains goal was to
isolate the sacred timeline according to
director Kate Heron from the timelines
of the other variants in the Kang
Dynasty so this opening date swipe is
this one playright frantically flipping
back to this date to set into motion a
plan to hold off his screaming cousins
in that Arena we see a slightly
different variation on the events from
in game with different takes editing
changes and sound mixes and focal points
that make it familiar but somewhat off
like this is the same establishing shot
that was used in endgame but with the
portal beam that chitauri and some
explosions removed because the battle
has ended this moment is also slightly
different on my way down to coordinate
search and rescue on my way down to
coordinate search and rescue on my way
down to coordinate search and rescue on
my way down to coordinate search and
rescue in the new take Loki Steve Rogers
impression is far more robotic and yes
this calls back to when Loki
impersonated Steve Rogers and Thor the
Dark World but either way right off the
bat we are clued into the fact that
there are alterations to the timeline
unlike in the film when we stayed on
Hulk's reaction to Loki's taunting wave
this time we stay on Loki as the
elevator doors Clos and he descends to
the lobby really the show is very much
about Loki in elevators because we are
already seeing a branch in the sacred
timeline at this point just by The
Avengers looping back to this point in
time little Butterfly Effects have
started to ripple effect and change
things another little change in the
original scene when the Tess slit out of
the briefcase to Loki's feet it made no
sound but now it has a full Coral hum to
it Loki believes that the tesser ACT is
a main part of his glorious purpose of
achieving god king status and this
episode slaps that belief right out of
him and it's actually shown later in the
episode when the hum dies away after he
realizes there are an infinite number of
useless Infinity Stones in that drawer
and really all this time he's just been
trying to get his hands on a glorified
paper weight we actually got a lot of
those some of the guys use them as paper
weights as Loki grabs the space Stone
and disappears we hear Thor's panicked
voice calling out back in the timeline
where's Loki Loki Loki just altered
history creating a branch timeline and
we see the altered Marvel Studios title
logo now in Loki signature green and
gold colors we cut to this bug crawling
reflected and a drop of water in the
goby desert the sky opens up and Loki
crashes into the sand recalling the
moment in quantam Mania when Kang crash
lands into the quantum realm the shot
composition is also reminiscent of Iron
Man's desert Landing three characters
who are prone to egomania but whereas
Kang digs in and doubles down Tony
evolves into someone more selfless and
Loki really could go down either of
those paths at this point Loki greets
the locals with his line from The
Avengers and is hilariously shut down
instantly foreshadowing the journey he's
about to go on I am Loki of asard and I
am burdened with glorious
purpose and again glorious purpose is
the title of this first episode and we
see Loki's glorious purpose changing
from conqueror to compliant variant just
as in this series we're seeing the
spectrum of kangs shifting from the
conquerer who's trapped in the quantum
realm to the one we meet in this series
the one who remains trying to keep the
Multiverse from unraveling that is a
journey Loki will go on a group of time
cops from the TVA show up TVA of course
the time variance Authority who I have
to say kind of a throwaway entity in the
Marvel Comics but in this show so
freaking cool this group is led by
Hunter B15 played by wmi mosaku and you
can see hash marks on her helmet perhaps
marking how many timelines she has reset
she keeps track of it this way because
otherwise the members of the TVA have no
other way of keeping track of time this
entrance by portal opening and holding
this handheld device definitely reminds
me of anytime AI showed up on quantum s
there seem to be a few knots to other
time travel shows throughout Loki we'll
talk about them as we go on B15 scanner
Loki is labeled variant l113 and you'll
notice the units Dro from five toward
zero the soldiers carry batons with
glowing tips some glow orange some glow
purple purple is really the signature
colors of Kang that is more dangerous of
the two colors B15 Wallops Loki across
the face forcing him to feel the pain of
this hit in time dilated slow motion
it's so simple of a visual effect but
it's so effective forcing Loki into this
humil humiliation of his flapping lips
because he's always running his mouth
wound me mosaku also plays an admin who
tortures Wyatt Russell via time dilation
in the Black Mirror episode play test so
Loki is taken into custody and the
timeline is pruned using a reset charge
that changes from Orange to purple the
sound the reset charge makes actually
sounds a lot like that bug crawling
across the
[Music]
sand so just like the footsteps of that
bug across the desert sand erased by the
wind so too this Branch timeline swept
from existence so as they enter the TVA
you can see the moment when the tessera
stops glowing as it is sapped of any
magic the interior of the TVA uses a lot
of 70 style orange tones and the circle
designs on the ceiling throughout the
building reminded me of the TARDIS on
dror who I do miss Popa
buttons everything's so swipy these days
it also might just be because the new
promos featuring Loki and Sylvia and
McDonald's for season 2 but the bright
colors and plastic Furniture definitely
look like the inside of a McDonald's to
me actually the TV a as a whole is
colorcoded so that the walls and outfits
are orange on the bottom security level
green on the mid-tier office level and
then gold on the top tier legal level we
actually see a scroll variant and he's
wearing a tracksuit so maybe there is a
scroll in the tracksuit Mafia in Hawkeye
I got to wonder which side of the two
scroll factions we saw in secret
Invasion this guy's on B15 uses a Time
twister to rewind Loki in the comics the
time Twisters are be that move backward
in time to destroy all in their path
here the device is a remote leash to
whoever wears the collar comedian Josh
fatum came is playing variant Martin
possibly based on Farmer bro Martin scy
my dad is on boor of gold St one little
call and your whole job is private we
also see comedian Eugene Cordo playing
the TVA clerk Casey who always seems
confused and frazzled he's so good on
this series the pens in his pocket leak
more and more ink into his shirt
throughout the episode he comments that
the Tesa sounds dumb which sets up what
we find out later that here the Infinity
Stones have no real value Loki is
stripped naked by this disturbing robot
with a face on its screen he looks a bit
like Herby from the comics who was a
robot sidekick of the Fantastic 4 but
everything from this slow smile to the
Glitchy eye just so unsettling even
before it removes Loki's clothes and
plops them into a prison jumpsuit this
whole scene is similar to the scene in
Thor Ragnarok when stanlee gives Thor a
haircut that don't you move my hands
aren't as steady as they used to be in
the transcript room Loki's greeted by an
adorable purring cat whose face is also
on the mug the cat's owner is playing
solitire on his screen which reminds me
of this moment in The Avengers Batman is
playing
Galaga thought we wouldn't
notice but we did the clock on the wall
has multiple hands and way too many
numbers on it just like all the clocks
in the TVA kind of like in a casino TVA
Employees are trapped from knowing what
time it really is it is a prison and in
keeping with old technology Loki's
transcript which should probably be way
longer than this prints from a dot
matrix printer Loki falls through the
floor again and lands in front of this
metal detector looking machine that
scans someone's temporal Aura and
ensures that they're not a robot and
then melts them from the inside if they
are this moment definitely hits
differently when you find out later that
the timekeepers themselves are
Chuck-E-Cheese style robots being
controlled by he who remains Loki asks
what if I was a robot and I didn't know
it yes a bit of existential Panic
underlying this whole season do any of
us have free will in he who remains
scripted reality or are we his Clockwork
his machines in the line room with all
the stanions it looks like a DMV there's
a poster on the wall showing M minutes
warning beave or you'll get your clock
cleaned and then we get this explanatory
video from Miss minutes who in trailers
for season 2 is even more terrifying
than we initially thought and was with a
version of Victor timley at the World's
Fair in Chicago in 1893 which I think
might have been the origin of this
entire TVA bureaucracy this video has a
distinct Jurassic Park Mr DNA video vibe
to it but I made another video recently
about Mis minutes explaining that Kate
harron's original idea in this episode
was for Mis minutes to jump off the
screen in this pilot episode and that
the designers from Luma VFX said that
they based her on Felix the Cat and
Betty Boop and that this welcome video
was based on the propaganda videos from
the 1950s like one called A is for atom
about atomic energy and another one
called destination Earth about oil made
by an oil company so at the end of the
video when it says produced by the time
variance Authority narrative commission
yeah we definitely get a sense that this
is all it's hiding the fact
that the temporal energy that they are
processing in this facility is extremely
volatile Miss minutes is of course
voiced by terara strong who also came
back to voice Mainframe in Guardians of
the Galaxy volume 3 welcome to the time
variance Authority I'm Miss Min and it's
my job to catch you up before you stand
trial for your crimes I love how Miss
minutes is locked up in a cuckoo clock
initially the bars of the clock
mimicking prison bars and the Pendulum
is actually a prison ball and chain I
just noticed this then we get a
Thunderclap and a bunch of Starbursts
the imagery almost matching frame for
frame the A is for Adam video Miss
minutes explains long ago there was a
vast multiversal War countless unique
timelines battled each other for
Supremacy nearly resulting in the total
Destruction of
well everything so these events are what
Reed Richards will later refer to in
Multiverse of Madness as incursions when
the boundary between Universe erodes and
they Collide destroying one or both of
those universes Miss minut goes on to
say that the all knowing timekeepers
reorganize the Multiverse into a single
timeline also among this animated
imagery we see these Waring alien races
which I think are the cre versus the
Titans we see similarly armored cre in
the Marvel's film and the purple ones
look like the residents of thanos's Home
world of Titan then we see this little
yellow example in a hat and bow tie and
his variant switch always keeping the
bow tie from a sea captain big musly guy
who reminded me of Bluto from Popeye and
then a mugad man and a James Bond style
mad scientist with an eye patch and then
a guy in a top hat which kind of
resembles Loki and M's look in the
trailer for season 2 Miss Mes explains
that stepping off a path creates a Nexus
event which could lead to another
multiversal War now since this is a
rewatch we know that this is all
it's a story concocted by he
who remains to maintain order and
prevent the Kang variants from seizing
power but like any good propaganda there
are are enough truths scattered
throughout to make it sound plausible
the video ends and Loki says this
timekeepers the sacred timeline who
actually believes this bunam and later
on this episode he'll add the idea that
your little Club decides the fate of
trillions of people across all of
existence at the beest of three space
lizards yes it's funny it's absurd so he
actually gets it correct right off the
bat this is bunkum lies designed to
maintain control and the timekeepers are
in fact fake and in the Mania post
credit scene one of the Kang variants is
a reptilian lizard so Martin gets
terrifyingly reset and the way he
screams it does not sound like a
pleasant experience raising your voice
with me bucket
head so these main titles were done by
The Design Lab perception in a white
fuzzy glow on a black background and you
can see one of the O's say little horns
like Loki's horned Crown the people of
perception stated we designed the
opening title for the series to pay
homage to Loki ship shifting nature
texts from previous films title
sequences and comic books that Loki has
appeared in Alien topography from the
series and even Norse runes can be seen
flickering throughout the logo then we
meet agent Mobius Owen Wilson in France
1549 he's based on Mobius M Mobius from
the comics he's investigating the
killings of hunters and Minutemen by a
mystery murderer who turns out later to
be Sylvie a female variant of Loki
played by Sophia D Martino she lured
them here to steal their reset charges
using this kaboy gum and anachronistic
item left in the past that they would
then have to come and deal with with but
it does show something nice about this
character that she gave the gum to a kid
so there is a heart in there mobus is
handed Loki variant l1130 rap sheet and
we see that he is Loki lyson son of ly
that's the yodenheim frost giant from
the first Thor movie and he goes by the
name Loki odinson because he didn't
actually know he was LA's son until the
events of Thor But the Sex is listed as
fluid which is just a cluee pointing to
the fact that different variants can
have different Sexes now a long time new
rockstars viewers know how much we use
geology and how long we've been using it
for but if this is your first time
hearing about geology get ready for
Blockbuster quality skinc Care on a
student film budget geology is a 23 time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
gi's products are just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades geology can help you fight acne
reduce oiless prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
everything you need to keep your skin
healthy no matter how much you soak in
the pool this summer don't know where to
start geology can create a simple and
effective skincare or hair care routine
for you all you got to do is take a
quick 30 second quiz right now if you
use the code new rockstars 100 geology
will give you 100% off their award
winning skincare trial set you'll also
get an additional bonus offer of up to
30% off one skin hair or body products
when you add it to your trial it's truly
a wild offer one of the best they've
ever given our audience so click the
link in the descript description or go
to G log. i/ rockstars 100 to get
started in the courtroom there are
murals all over the wall showing TVA
clerics technicians and judges one of
whom is wearing glasses and a mustache
kind of looking like a younger stanlee
we meet Justice Rana RN Slayer played by
Goo maatha sitting in front of the
looming faces of the three timekeepers
and sitting directly in front of the
kissing lips of the center one in the
comics she was the love of Kang the
Conqueror and she threw herself in front
of a blast to save his life in season
two her other identity Rebecca tormin be
beside Victor timley in that 1893 era
Loki tries to shift blame to the
Avengers and their Time Heist but Rin
Slayer shoots him down we're not here to
talk about the Avengers oh no no what
they did was supposed to happen you
escaping was not so what the Avengers
did was given the okay by he who remains
and when they put the Infinity Stones
back it set the timeline right again but
still I've always interpreted this to
mean he who remains wanted the Avengers
to break the rules of time travel to
defeat Thanos Loki has some embarrassing
performance issues how do you plead
guilty of
[Music]
this what's going on yeah magic doesn't
work in the TVA Ren Slayer pronounces
him guilty and sentences him to be reset
but Mobius intervenes and takes Loki on
a little tour of the TVA it seems
massive one of the spires is labeled
t282 which could be a not to Thor issue
282 which was our first appearance of
the timekeepers they get to the elevator
and the elevator buttons have these
three character Al a numeric code that
many of us online have tried to decipher
over the years but so far they don't
seem to refer to anything specific maybe
we'll get some answers in season 2 but
the in credits we do see one of those
codes again 1 EJ and it's immediately
hit with access denied maybe it's to the
automat and someone's trying to double
dip on slices of key line pie in the
time theater Mobius cracks open a Justa
a discontinued soft drink from the 90s
made by pepsic Co and was marketed as a
high energy drink it was only around
from 1995 to 1999 I thought maybe based
off this that Loki could be from the
late '90s but in the season 2 trailer
his pass say a jet ski salesman is rumor
has it the scene set in 2022 Loki tells
Mobius that he wanted to rule over
midgard and then eventually all of space
and Mobius replies why does someone with
so much
range just want to rule this is perhaps
some meta commentary on comic book
villains just always wanting power but
for no real reason and Loki responds I
would have made it easy for them the
first and most oppressive lie ever
rotted was the song of freedom for
nearly every living thing Choice
breathes shame and uncertainty and
regret this is similar to what Loki said
in Germany is this not isia and mobus
shows him this moment among his greatest
hits in the TVA hollow projector the
bright Le of Freedom diminishes your
life's joy in a mad Scramble for power
we see the events from the previous
films Loki killing Coulson Loki stealing
that eyeball and then the Battle of New
York freezes on the waitress Beth played
by athley Johnson or Chrissy stver from
growing pains and the voice of Ellie in
The Last of Us games and who played
Ellie's mom in The Last of Us HBO series
there was actually a Steve Rogers
subplot that got cut from that film
perhaps we can now look at that as a
prune Branch storyline Mobius reveals
that Loki was real life mystery hijacker
DB Cooper a man who hijacked a Northwest
orian Airlines flight in 1971 by saying
he had a bomb and then demanded $200,000
and parachuted out over to Washington it
was never found or identified Captain
will Scott William Scott was actually
the name of the pilot on that flight
here heimall catches Loki with the
bifrost leaving cash floating and noted
the fact that all they ever found of DB
Cooper was some cash floating in the
Columbia River Loki apparently did all
this because he lost a bet to Thor
Mobius tells Loki that he wants to know
what makes Loki tick which is true since
he is hunting Sylvie and he needs to
know why she is doing what she's doing
and Loki once again gets it right I know
what this place is what is it it's an
illusion as a trickster prone to weaving
Illusions himself Loki can spot the
Macan naations behind what the TVA is
presenting him we see fr's death from
Thor the Dark World and events that are
still in the future from this point for
this Loki and it's kind of like that
scene in Scrooged when the Ghost of
Christmas Past tells Frank that even the
worst people cry when they see memories
of their mothers Merry Christmas Frankie
Angel Merry Christmas to you
Mama Niagara Falls Frankie
Angel Mobius helps Loki up and this is
the moment Loki picks his pocket if you
look closely he uses b15s entrance is a
distraction the projected Avengers
rotate counterclockwise but when we cut
back to Loki after Mobius leaves they
rotate clockwise maybe because Loki
stealing the time twister might not have
been part of he remains plan Loki's on
kind of a brief Branch timeline before
he Loops back to this room at the end of
the episode that's why when he comes
back to this room later as movus wants
him to it rotates the correct way again
Loki sees another variant in the
background being detained and this one
kind of looks like Peggy Carter which
kind of would make sense if Steve Rogers
going back with Peggy and ingame created
a branch timeline like the film's
directors claimed it did headwriter Mike
Waldren was asked about this after
episode 1 if Peggy and Steve were
targeted by the TV for doing that and he
said that's a good question man I don't
think I can answer that I think maybe
just keep watching so whether this
variant was supposed to be confirmation
or we haven't got the answer to that yet
only time will tell Loki tells Casey
give me the Tes aactor I'll gut you like
a fish Casey which could be a n to this
scene in Scream with Drew Barrymore
whose character is also named Casey if
you hang up on me again I'll got you
like a fish Loki gets a test rack back
and he sees a drawer filled with
Infinity Stones along with many other
interesting things a super rare t206
Honus Wagner baseball card a military
medal a crucifix a casino chip and I
just noticed this there is a white
realtoreal tape box with what looks like
the word Watergate on it so it's
possible that the missing 18 minutes
from rosemary Woods Watergate tapes what
would have been the Smoking Gun for
Richard Nixon were in this drawer later
in the end credits you can see a
mindstone being used as a paper weight
just like what Casey says some of the
others use them for sad music play as as
Loki realizes he's been chasing
something useless and he says is this
the greatest power in the
universe I love how Casey sort of face
drugs at this rhetorical question
because like dude has no idea he spends
all of his time behind a desk he doesn't
even know what a fish is on the screen
we actually see VOR the location of the
Soul Stone confirming that these
Infinity Stones are indeed real when
Loki returns to that projection room he
drops the Tesseract which now just makes
a regular Hollow plunk noise as it hits
the ground since it no longer holds any
meaning for him
here Loki returns to fr's
death this violin melody was composed by
Loki composer Natalie Holt who actually
egged Simon cowl for ruining the music
industry when she worked as a backup
musician on Britain's Got Talent Loki
also sees Odin's death I love you my
sons ah we see that great Heston
reaction shot when Odin calls him a son
too then finally Loki sees his own death
and the film strip which is labeled 616
plays out as Thor Mourns his brother
interestingly the film strip runs beyond
the moment of Loki's death so really he
remains wanted Loki to see Thor's
reaction Loki began this episode with a
belief that he had a glorious purpose
but now seeing himself and everyone else
in his life die and his precious
Infinity Stones robbed of any power and
meaning he has no purpose he needs a new
glorious purpose and in his despair he's
finally able to tell Mobius the truth I
don't enjoy hurting people I don't enjoy
it I do it because I have to because
I've had to because it's part of the
illusion it's the cruel elaborate trick
conjured by the weak to inspire fear now
that mobus has determined that has a
soul and isn't just a villain as this
whole episode has really been a void
contest do you have a soul or not Mobius
offers him a chance at Redemption by
helping him find the Loki variant that
has been killing TVA agents why me the
variant we're hunting
is you and we cut to an oil field in
Selena Oklahoma in 1858 Oklahoma by the
way the original comic site of new
Asgard after the events of Ragnarok if
you look closely at this tool the screen
shows it is a Quantum ore shovel
produced by aim from the early third
millennium so Sil Sy Springs her trap
grabbing the reset charge and setting
the field on fire her silhouette looking
very much like the demon in the stained
glass in the French Church what is
quantum or actually went into a whole
theory about that in my deep dive of the
entirety of Loki season 1 on the Deep
dive Channel now to talk briefly about
the end credits titles these were also
done by the design studio perception and
they said that this sequence quote was
based on the bureaucracy of the TVA and
seeing Loki through their eyes it is
filled with mundane depictions of
imagery within a typical office however
each of these elements is paired with
something magical to showcase the
otherworldly existence of the TV a some
examples of these include stacks of
files being held down by Infinity Stones
uses paper weights a water cooler with a
tidy timeline poster behind it and a
clock with more than the traditional
amount of hands so we first see Loki's
case File complete with a photo of him
and his thumb prints and underneath that
is a report about Loki's plea agreement
and there are names redacted there's a
coffee pot labeled fresh 800 BC just a
bit of that mundane mixed with the
magical there's a poster that says
hunters and analysts working in tandem
with an image of a nerdy analyst and a
badass Hunter maybe there's some in
office rivalry between the two groups
and this poster is a reminder that you
know we're all in this together folks
next to that poster are some pinned
equations and figures like figure R
variance we also see a bit of shrewd
dinger's equation dealing with the
shinger cat thought experiment from
physicist Irwin shinger that said that a
cat in a box with some poison is both
alive and dead until the Box is open
I've always wanted that cat that we saw
earlier in the transcript room to be a
variant version of shinger cat in a box
I just want its name to be schinger the
text with the credits jumps around on
the screen which perception said was a n
to jumping through time and then we see
a TVA apocalyptic event report that
lists failure to intervene in dire
circumstances under the details there's
another apocalyptic event report
describing Loki's involvement in the DB
Cooper plane hijacking and yet had
another Report with some thick research
books on top and then we see the TVA
Chrono monitoring handbook that is a
coffee ring stain on it which is
something else that comes up in episode
2 with mobus leaving coffee ring stains
on Ren slayer's side table there's some
light up switches on a board each
labeled with three values kind of like
the three characters on each elevator
button there's also a variant diagram
which shows a main figure with five
variants branching from it each one has
a different shaped head a square
triangle pentagon hexagon and just an X
kind of looking like the board game
Perfection there's some kaboy gum in an
Evidence bag a clock with a bunch of
hands one of which is moving backwards a
binder full of redactor reports we see
the Wake Magazine on Mia's desk that's a
jet SK one that's featured in episode 2
and we end on an image of the three
timekeeper faces in the courtroom at the
very end of the credits you can hear the
voice of Miss minutes thanks for
visiting the TVA don't hesitate to let
us know how we're doing and it is worth
noting that the in credit sequence
changes slightly with each episode new
photos or details are added and the
whole thing speeds up or slows down
based on the tone of the episode it's a
cool detail that shows how much
attention they PID to everything in the
series which will be something we
explore with breakdowns of episode 2 3
four 5 and six we're doing all of them
in the month of September as we look
ahead to Loki season 2 on October 6th we
want to make sure we caught every
possible detail from the first season
please subscribe to all three channels
in the new rockstars Network I want to
thank Gina EO for writing this re
breakdown you can follow me on all
social platforms at eaos follow new
rockstars and we'll see you next time
everyone thanks for watching
[Music]
bye